I would always tell people if you
disagree with him don't go on television
and criticize him just pick up the phone
and call him and go see him and he'll
talk to you about it he may not agree
with you but again that's what Kim
Kardashian did when she had a case of
clemency with a woman Alice Johnson that
she felt strongly about we went through
the case I wouldn't have had her call if
I didn't think it was a legitimate case
so we spent about eight months uh
quietly working through the case working
through the details to make sure that it
really was a worthy case um I brought it
to president Trump said you know she'd
like to come meet with you to to talk
about this case and he said Herman so
she came in we went through the case and
president Trump ultimately granted the
clemency to Alice Johnson who was a a
woman who was accused of being part of a
drug ring uh she had a basically a life
sentence uh for doing it she'd served 22
years in prison while in prison I mean
she's basically was a grandmother and
she um she was you know putting on the
prison plays she was mentoring you know
young women in prison somebody who again
there's always a risk but by and large
had a very very very low risk of of
committing a crime in the future and
then it goes back to the notion of are
we going to judge people by the worst
decision they make in their life and so
president Trump uh was willing to Grant
the climate scene it went and I think
that it just goes to the notion of like
maybe this goes back to his
unpredictability in a positive way which
is if you go sit with him and you make
your case he'll hear you he'll listen to
you and he's not afraid to act and he's
not afraid to be controversial which I
think is a good
thing